But fasting in general and specifically
in Ramadan, we've mentioned previously
that
fasting
is really an act that comprises
two
two things at once. When these two
things come together intentionally,
then a person is essentially fasting.
Because when we talk about fasting, what
are we what are we talking about? We're
talking about refraining. We're talking
about not doing something.
A person is refraining
from breaking their fast.
And this is a type of worship in itself.
When a person avoids all that is haram,
anything that is haram, this is an act
of refraining.
And worship
is essentially of five types.
You've got worship of the heart,
worship of the tongue,
worship of the body,
worship of a person's property
or wealth,
and then worship of
the worship of refraining
from something.
And then there are acts of worship which
are comprised of
more than one of these types of things
hajj for instance. Hajj is a type
of worship that includes all of these
five types.
It's an it's a worship of the heart of
the tongue of the body of a person's
wealth and
refraining because there are things that
a person in Hajj cannot do that he would
normally be able to do. So
fasting essentially
is comprised of two parts.
Number one that a person has intention.
Number two, that a person refrains
from anything that will break his fast.
That's it. When these two things come
together,
refraining from anything that will break
your fast with the intention of fasting,
this is what we refer to as fast. And a
person does this from the break of dawn
until the sun sets. This person has
fasted an entire day and this person has
con has been considered to be fasting.
So
these are referred to sometimes as
pillars by the scholars. Two pillars.
The pillars of fasting are number one
intention. Number two, that a person
refrain from anything that will break
his fast intentionally from the break of
dawn until the sun sets. Now, the
question here that comes into play, what
will break a person's fast?
What is it that breaks a person's fast?
A person's fast is broken by one of six
things. Anything outside of these six
things
will not break a person's fast. It may
deplete a person's reward of fasting.
It may
be preferred that a person not do it
while they're fasting.
It may have various rulings.
However,
when a person
is fasting, the only thing that will
invalidate his fast, meaning the person
has to start the day over on a different
day, is one of these six things.
And some scholars view them as being
five because one of the six things can
be included in another.
You'll see what we mean by that. The
first and second,
the first and second things that will
break a person's fast is eating anything
or drinking anything
on purpose. This additional word here is
very important. When we say on purpose,
meaning a person intentionally does it
knowing that he's fasting.
Let's say a person forgets that he's
fasting and eats a five course meal.
Does that break his fast? Absolutely
not.
Let's say a person forgets that he is
fasting
and eats or drinks anything
intentionally.
Even though they intentionally did it,
it was unintentional
as someone who is fasting. Therefore, a
person must have the intention, I know
that I am fasting and that this will
break my fast and then proceed to do it.
that will invalidate a person's fasting.
When the scholars say eating or drinking
anything,
eating or drinking doesn't necessarily
mean that it is food. It could be
something that is not food.
The point is is that anything that goes
path of food and drink
and that includes
the sinuses, the nasal
because the nose, you know, it connects
back into the back of the throat.
Well, how about
the eyes?
The answer is no. Not at all. Eye drops
do not break a person's fast.
A person may say, well, sometimes if a
person does an eye drops, they might
feel they're tasting it their
mouth. This does not break a person's
fast.
And
not one time has the prophet sallall.aii
Wasallam instructed us that this will
break their fast
nor any of his companions.
The path of food and drink is the throat
is the nose and the
mouth back of the throat.
We will continue this inshallah
next week. Again, the class is a
little bit shortened now because of
Ramadan. Usually, we start at about 20
25 minutes before Jum, but because of
Ramadan and people fasting and so forth,
doing it about 10 minutes inshallah.
week after next we'll go back to the
original timing.
[Silence]
Allahbar. Allahbar.
Allahbar. Allah
abbar.
ill
[Silence]
ash
Father
[Silence]
Hayah.
Hallelujah fell.
Halleluah.
Allahbarb.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Muslim.
[Silence]
Fore
speech. forch.
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
says in
that which translates to
And why is it
that you would not
spend your wealth in the way of Allah
knowing that Allah to he belongs the
inheritance of the heavens and the
earth.
This verse
is very striking in its meaning.
And that is that this entire chapter
is revealed regarding
the entire chapter its main narrative is
fighting in the way of Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
and that that ji head
is divided into two branches.
You have
jihad
that a person does with his body, with
his own soul,
and jihad which a person does with his
resources,
with all that a person has
the ability to give,
whether that be wealth or property.
Whether that be anything that a person
can use to financially
support
or to pour resources into the way and
the path of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala asks
rhetorically here in this verse
why would you not
spend your resources verses
in the way of Allah
being that Allah is the one who will
inherit
all of the heavens and the earth.
If a person saves and squirrels away
their resources
and does not give them for the sake of
Allah,
one of two things will happen. Number
one,
this person
will
die while these things are still
squirreled away.
Therefore, all of this
trouble that they went to to save all of
these resources
is for not because these resources will
then be divided
amongst your heirs.
People who didn't break a sweat, didn't
lift a finger to accumulate these
resources, they get them for free.
Or
number two, a person will finally spend
all of these resources on himself
on material things.
And these material things will
eventually go to someone else free of
charge.
Everything goes back into the box.
Everything.
Everything goes back into the earth
where it was created from
and
hence back to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And that is why one of the names of
Allah is
the great inheritor subhanahu wa ta'ala.
After all of the creation is dead,
after we are all
dust,
there will be none to claim our
inheritance, our collective inheritance
except for Allah.
To he belongs the inheritance of the
heavens and the earth. He tells us
subhanahu wa ta'ala
that he will collect back all that is
upon the earth. Everything that we have,
everything that belongs to us today will
belong to someone else tomorrow
and will eventually belong back to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala when there is no
tomorrow and there is no one else to
inherit.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala asks
this question
when he urges
when he demands
of the believers
to spend their wealth for the sake of
Allah and specifically
in the path of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
he asks this question
he says says,
"And why would you not
pour all of your resources
into the path of Allah,
or at least pour your resources into the
path of Allah, being that Allah is the
one who will inherit the heavens and the
earth
It will all eventually end up in the
same place.
There is a companion named Abdullah
Abdullah.
He came
to visit the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam.
And one night he came to see him while
the prophet was in salah
and he heard him reciting
the statement of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
the statement of Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
you all are being sidetracked act by the
momentary amusement
of
obtaining
those things, collecting
those things which are of
those things which make you feel like
you have a lot.
He says
[Silence]
He says the human being is constantly
fretting over his money.
constantly
constantly his mantra is my money my
money my wealth my wealth my property
mine mine
he says but oh son of Adam
do you really possess of your wealth
except that which you eat and physically
becomes a part of your body
or that which you put onto your body and
wear out
or that which you give for the sake of
Allah and you will find in the
hereafter. Those are one of three
things. Everything else goes right back
into the box.
If you are not
consuming it into your body
to where it becomes part of your flesh
and bones,
if you are not wearing it on your body,
if you are not giving it for the sake of
Allah and Allah accepts it from you and
rewards you for it in the hereafter, it
goes to someone else. No matter how much
it is, no matter how much your name is
written all over it, no matter if it has
a pin a pin number that only you know
and no one can get into it except for
you with your PIN number, protect your
PIN number.
Or no matter if you have it in an
account and a trust and you have so many
people looking after it to make sure
that no one can access this these
resources except for you and whom you
deem
all of it will go back into the box
eventually.
And hey, we live in America.
Any money that is left unattended or any
taxes that are not paid on it, it goes
to the lovely government for free of
charge. We could add that one on to it
as well.
Any of it because of course we wouldn't
want a single dime to go
unaccounted for.
And so the point here is that
what we have our name on doesn't
necessarily belong to us.
Everything that we have been given in
this life,
we have been given momentarily
as a tool,
as a puzzle piece that will make up our
journey.
Nothing more than that. It's not part of
you.
It is only yours by claim at this point
at this junction.
Think about it. Everything right now
that we have, we inherited from
generations that came before us.
Everything. Everything.
Even our own bodies are made up of the
same dirt and the same earth that the
previous nations were made of.
We don't even get to keep our own flesh
and blood.
It goes back into the ground and
the ground will take back everything
that it gave us.
And that is the nature
of our relationship with the earth that
we reside upon.
Today we are the ones that are living on
this earth and it nourishes us and
tomorrow
we will be inside of that earth and we
will be nourishing it back and it will
take back everything that it gave us.
You don't get to keep anything. The only
thing that you get to keep
is what has gone through to the
hereafter.
As our prophet said,
[Silence]
He said, "Human being, do you really
really possess
anything beyond
what you eat or what you wear
or what you give for the sake of Allah
and it goes to the next life." That is
the only three things.
And when we say what you wear, what you
eat, not what you have, planning to wear
and planning to eat. No, no, no. What
you've already eaten or wearing right
now.
That's it. That's all you get.
No more.
Everything else goes back into the box.
It gets recycled for the coming
generations that will live on this earth
after us.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam
posed a similar question to his
companions
and Muslim the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam said to his companions one day
He said, "Who of you cares more about
your heir's wealth than your own?"
Meaning, when a person dies,
their heir will inherit from them. A
person cares more about what they
inherit, not about what their heir will
take from them. And so the companion
said, "Oh messenger of Allah, of course
every one of us cares more about our own
wealth than our heirs." He said,
"Whatever you give for the sake of Allah
is yours.
And whatever you do not that belongs to
your heirs,
not just to your kids and your your
heirs, those who will inherit from you."
No, no, no. your heirs, meaning anyone
that will live on this earth after you.
But this is very contradictory
to what we are
enveloped with here in this society
today.
You see, we all grow up and we all are
in an environment that teaches us that
this
this is fiscally irresponsible. What you
are saying, she
what do you mean?
Well,
you have to go to school
and you have to get a career
and you can't spend any of that money.
You've got to save it up
so that when you retire, you've got
something to draw from. So that you can
go see the world once you retire. so
that when you get married you can throw
have a big wedding, you know, stuff like
that. You've got to save every penny.
You know what's interesting?
Very, very few of us are able to live
this reality anymore.
It's 2026 in America.
Everyone and his brother has his hand
out to collect his subscription of the
month. Not one of us is saving anything.
Most Americans are in debt because we
live in the country of you don't have to
have money to buy something. Buy it and
then pay me later. That's where we are.
We're not saving anything. We've got a
subscription for everything except for
the air we breathe. And that is coming
down the pike.
We don't save anymore.
And even if we did, back to what our
prophet taught us. These are not new
values.
Our prophet sallall.aii wasallam taught
his wives. He said to his wife, he said
to his wife, Zan,
he taught his companions and his own
wives,
give for the sake of Allah and Allah
will give to you. The idea that you can
somehow bend the world to your will
by merely squandering and squirreling
away money. That doesn't mean anything.
You are dealing with Allah.
When you give, Allah gives to you. You
withhold, Allah withholds from you.
Even if you think
that you are
that you are somehow getting ahead,
the only true wealth is that which
survives you upon your death
and that is your wealth with Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala in the hereafter.
That is the only wealth
that will
that will continue beyond
[Arabic recitation]
after the salah we are going to be
fundraising for Rahma Academy. Rahma
Academy
is our school here at this masjid for
the community here in Tucson for the
children.
This school
is absolutely critical to our religion
survival in this country.
That is that
in our public schools today,
your children, our children
are being taught themes of
homosexuality,
of hypersexuality,
of godlessness,
of
scientific hubris,
of religiouslessness,
of moral depravity.
And the only way that we can protect our
children is to teach them ourselves.
Now, our school might not be perfect.
It might not be exactly what every
single person thinks it should be and
thinks it would be had they been the
ones in charge of it. That's the nature
of authority and leadership.
Not everyone is going to be pleased.
But there are two types of people. There
are those who are truly with their
brothers and sisters and feel a an
obligation, a kind of ownership
that if something is wrong, I will stick
with it to try to help it or better it.
And those who are not, they're there as
long as what they want happens. If what
they want doesn't happen, they'll just
go somewhere else and take their
business somewhere else. If they if
McDonald's doesn't treat them right,
they'll go over here to Burger King,
right? That's a second type of person.
We have to stick together and whether it
is your child or my child, it is our
child and every one of us will share in
the responsibility
of ensuring that our children are
insulated to an extent from the
depravity that larger society around us
is engaging in, is indulging in, is
normalizing.
And there's only so much we can do. But
this
is absolutely the least we can do.
There is not one reason for any one of
us today to walk out of this masid
without contributing
something.
Contribute $100.
The amount of money you give to
Starbucks, the amount of money you give
to Netflix every year to show you
programs about people with fake smiles
and fake lives and entertain you and
escape for a little bit from this world.
For less money, you will be contributing
to something that is truly eternal,
inshallah, eternally with Allah.
There is not a single excuse that one of
us will have to walk out of this masjid
without contributing something.
And most of us can contribute a lot more
than just something.
And so with that inshallah
we ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
to guide us to guide us to truly spend
our wealth and resources in the way that
pleases him. We ask him subhanahu wa
ta'ala to accept from us. We ask him
subhanahu wa ta'ala to give us the
insight to recognize the truth when
we hear it. the strength and courage to
adhere to that truth in spite of the
consequences and the honor and nobility
of dying for and upon that truth and
being resurrected upon it. Allah
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
All
[Silence]
you
sore.
So stand shouldertosh shoulder. Close
all of the gaps. Align your shoulders
and feet with the shoulders and feet of
your two neighbors.
As we mentioned, as the rows are being
straightened,
we're going to be fundraising for about
five minutes after the salah is over. We
each have two responsibilities towards
this fundraising.
Number one, do not get up and leave
unless you absolutely have some kind of
emergency and cannot spare five minutes
because one person leaves, the other
person leaves, and we all have the idea
that someone else is doing what needs to
be done, but it's actually us that needs
to do it. The least you can do, just
stay for three, four, five minutes while
we raise these funds for our children.
Number two, do not leave the masid
without contributing something.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Amen.
Don't worry.
[Silence]
All
me Allah
hid.
All
[Arabic recitation]
alalaykum.
First, I want to thank Sheh Ali for such
a wonderful, very encouraging.
, but I want to just emphasize on the
need for this. So alhamdulillah as you
know we have al 90 students at the Rahma
Academy alhamdulillah takir
now that's our goal was always like
about 100 students and we are reaching
that fast now what happens after that is
what we need is the expansion of the
Rahma academy in a physical
infrastructure
the sense so for that purpose Allahh has
blessed us
we have now 1 acre parcel on this
street. Takb
takb
brothers and sisters, we have 1 acre
parcel that has already been paid for.
What we need to raise funds from now on
is to build a school building on that
lot. So without any further delay and
again this is going to be a walk that's
that's all the attributes she talked
about and why you should give this is a
saddaka jar. So all you need to realize
is this is a per perpetuity where you
are getting the reward that where you're
going to get the reward for every time
the student is learning something
something about the deen is being taught
in this school. So again it is a Islamic
school we focus on that and now we have
a very good news inshallah to share with
you some other day. So without any
further delay I'm going to request sheh
Ali to help us raise some money
inshallah make some pledges.
[Arabic recitation]
inshallah with $10,000. Look, when you
well when we say pledge this amount
or that amount, you don't have to pay it
all right now this second. You can
pledge it, make sure that it is is down
and then you can pay it weekly, monthly,
bi-weekly, you can pay it within a year.
Just pledge something and make sure that
you follow through with that pledge.
Inshallah, let us start with $10,000.
We should get at least
brother
[Arabic recitation]
$10,000.
five more. $10,000 for the entire
year.$10,000.
10,000. You can pay it throughout the
year.
[Arabic recitation]
mention his name.
as you can. This will encourage everyone
else. You need to be public. If
everybody hides himself, then we're not
going to see it. $10,000
Let's have a few more inshallah. 10,000.
I see scrubs in the masid. I see
doctors. I see professionals. I see guys
with a pension. $10,000 inshallah.
10,000.
Not to take too much time. We'll move on
inshallah to
[Arabic recitation]
Amen.
are pledging, right? The board members,
the people that are working here. We
well, not working, but volunteering. We
need everyone to be involved in this.
Every single one of us right now must
get involved in this in some way. But
you'll move on, not to take up too much
time. Here we have another here in the
[Arabic recitation]
10,000 or we on 5,000?
Mashallah. 10,000. Any more before we
move on? $10,000 throughout the year.
Come on. It's America's 2026. It costs
about 20 bucks for a loaf of bread. Now,
we have here upstairs sis. So, it's
all of the board members. We need
some more regular members. 10,000.
Let us move on quickly to $5,000.
Inshallah. We should we should take
these nothing. 5,000 here.
We have 5,000 over here, brothers. 5,000
here in the front. Brother Sham said
[Arabic recitation]
5,000.
opportunity.
[Arabic recitation]
throughout the year.
5,000.
[Arabic recitation]
we have two. You don't know. This might
be the one thing
is accepted from you. This might be your
ticket into paradise. If you knew we
have here in the back, brother
could be the one thing that tips your
scales into paradise. And if that were
the case, how much would you give right
now? If you knew that that was your one
ticket to paradise, how would you give
it that you could sleep soundly after
today? 5,000. 5,000.
Let's take 5. We have another over here.
Mashallah.
Amen.
Okay, very quickly, not to take up too
much time. $2,000.
We should have just people fighting,
chomping at the bit right now. $2,000
2,000 over here by the wall as well.
here by the wall. 2,000
[Arabic recitation]
brother 2,000
it now
[Arabic recitation]
Who else can take this 2,000 over here
this over here $2,000
[Arabic recitation]
there's a brother
Amen.
[Arabic recitation]
move on. And if we miss you, please make
sure that you take it. Here we have a
sister upstairs in the front. Mashallah.
[Arabic recitation]
Oh, mashallah. Took it for someone else.
We have here 25. 25 here in the front.
you sister here. And then we've got a
little boy with his parents' money
throwing it down from the balcony.
Mashallah. Jude is throwing his mother's
wallet down from upstairs. 2,000
[Arabic recitation]
down to 1,000 for the sake of time.
1,000. Less than a hundred bucks a
month. You spend more on coffee. You
spend more at the gas station for your
kids. You spend more on Netflix.
thousand bucks for the year we have over
here a thousand a thousand all the
students should be given you want to get
married right this is how you get money
and have some kind of something in the
bank with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala get
yourself a nice wife get yourself a nice
husband $1,000 for the year $1,000 for
the year we should have them just coming
out of the woodworks over here 10,000
Amen.
[Arabic recitation]
mother's wallet down as well from the
balcony. Uhhuh. And Sala from upstairs.
Mashallah.
[Arabic recitation]
Abdi. 1,000.
as off as some of the board members.
So inshallah I'll get there once I
once you start paying me more I'll start
[Arabic recitation]
here. MASHALLAH 1,000
LESS THAN A hundred bucks a month.
$1,000 inshallah every for the entire
year. $1,000.
$1,000. Inshallah we're going to stop
that we have here in the back.
Mashallah.
Amen.
[Arabic recitation]
right now to build our children a future
and not have to ask anyone and teach
them what we want them to know, not what
someone else imposes on them. This is
our jihad. It's our responsibility. We
will end it there. Inshallah. Should we
go with Yeah, we can end it there. If
you have anything else to contribute,
make sure that you sign up before you
leave. Do not leave without giving
something. Give a hundred bucks on your
way out. Give something. Even if only
for the we've heard today, give
something.
Anybody I mean obviously there's a box
back there and you can donate, put it in
the box. ask anybody who does not want
to say anything just you can put that
you know the the note in there with the
name that will be inshallah we'll follow
up on it. the couple of other
announcements that we need to make I
must make. first is the camel will
start on between the Monday and Tuesday
night will start between Monday and
Tuesday night and that will be at 4 at 4
a.m. inshallah and sahur will be served
here in in the masjid. there is a
there's a fitter is $15 per person for
everybody in the household inshallah.
and brother Ahmed Jabar you have you
have announcement
[Arabic recitation]
allayikum we did not catch all the names
so if somebody pledge please come and
just give us your name here I also have
a very important amount announcement
pertaining to the school and it's very
exciting actually I just want you to
know that the school kids participated
in the southern Arizona science fair
this year and we have 10 students who
participated from grades 1 to three. We
have four students from grade 1, four
students from grade two, and two
students from grade three. I just want
to let you know that mashallah nine out
of the 10 are winners today. We just got
the announcement an hour ago and
tomorrow inshallah they will be
recognized in public by the SFS in the
park and I'll have more informations
about that. But I have the duty to
mention their names and thank their
teachers. On the first grade I have Jude
Petar.
I also have Malik El Malik Alarville.
Mashallah.
I have Zar Ahmed. Mashallah.
And I have Zuber Ali. These are first
grade teacher Elisha Roat Jazaki Lafer.
In the second grade, I have Amir Al
Ble. I'm sorry if I misname.
I have Ralia El Kabash.
I have Maria Abd
and I have Muhammad Ali Jazak. This is
under teacher Amal Al Fatak teacher. And
in the third grade, I have one person
out of two who won. And the third grade
person is Muhammad Ali. I know I
mentioned him before. I'm sorry I did a
mistake maybe. and thank you teacher
Ishra. I'm sorry I just got this news
about an hour ago and I didn't have time
to announce it. So you should be proud
of your school
in introduced to and showed you how
important it is how important it is that
you bring your children here. But we
want you to know that we work hard and
we go out of our way to even reach out
to all the activities anything we can do
to improve the school on a scientific
and secular level. So please
participate.
Okay. Second grade person that I missed
is Mik Hass.
Congratulations to everybody. Sorry for
the missing that.
[Arabic recitation]
One.
Make sure you get every single one of
them.
[Arabic recitation]
house.
give me your name and tell me how you
want to pay it and it'll be fine.
[Arabic recitation]
know
my son was doing it
in charge.
So, and IBM, we used to do that all the
time. ,
[Arabic recitation]
afterwards. Can I get your number?
That's how it chose them.
Whatever way you want to write.
Okay.
post.
I will see what I can
[Silence]
MCC
or NC
[Silence]
is thanks to
Okay. And the monthly, do you want to
set it up? The same.
Okay. This one you can set it up.
Choose the donate. Then you say monthly
notes right.
How do you
[Arabic recitation]
Let's do that.
the month. But for zel
I don't.
Okay.
I give it to you.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
Today is
[Silence]
Can you just put me down,000? What's
your name? Huh?